the sidemen did this charity soccer game
it was [ __ ] unbelievable I think it
had like 30 million viewers like
millions of people watching it live go
are they like KSI girls in relationships
they [ __ ] them no to the side no that's
no no that's not the RL no it's actually
uh to from a guy we interviewed for a
couple hours in London we flew to
interview him
he mentioned him he didn't mentioned
them
you mentioned the uh so KSI and his boys
are known as the sidemen and they did
this charity tournament they sold 27 000
tickets to watch them play like a
celebrity soccer match against like
YouTubers and they speed they raised
over a million dollars they raised over
a million dollars for what for some
tried I don't know which one but
um
anyway the point is I speed this kid's
speed is unbelievably entertaining and
he's just took over the whole like the
only Clips you're seeing from this are
about him yeah I haven't seen anything
go viral but no there's the one kid I
forgot his name the streamer that had
like an amazing goal shot from like
Hatfield basically speed nice Definitely
yeah to me that was speed it was nice
Beast B scoreboard he was offsides oh
but still even better
we want to see him do is the soup e yeah
you know I mean he got close to Turning
soccer in the WWE which objectively
makes everything better I mean that's
what you want to do with the Celeb games
like that's what they would do back in
the day like uh we you remember the MTV
uh celebrity basketball game The Rock
and Josh yeah yeah and it was wrestling
and basketball yeah those were great wow
that's cool they had like a 10-point rim
that was higher yeah that's awesome yeah
it was great it was fun and uh but this
is just so [ __ ] inspiring and
unbelievable like what their first time
soccer was ever fun this is the first
time I pretended to be Ronaldo first
time
I mean this is also crazy Reckless this
is the thing I think we're talking about
this before Oh did he plan this did he
like tell KSI like hey bro the second
KSI touches the soccer ball is at the
beginning of the match 16 seconds in
16 seconds this makes this so much
funnier speed runs top speed from across
the field and slide tackles KSI and
makes him do like a [ __ ] front flip
it's unbelievable
[Applause]
this ksi's worth tens of millions of
dollars he's a he's a boxer
[Applause]
did he touch the ball first oh [ __ ]
he didn't even check on him bro he
almost did I do that he might have been
injured the whole game Reggie breaks his
ankle in the whole side KSI soccer game
he's not done it's kind of crazy but
then that's why it's fun yeah he's
barking backstage with people like it
was just unbelievable he apparently
spent 17 minutes offsides
[Laughter]
17 minutes of the game he was not
actually eligible to get the ball but
unbelievably entertaining and can just
turn it on this is the thing we were
talking about before I don't understand
how he's like a kid from Cincinnati he's
20 years old yeah I don't understand how
he has this level of Showmanship and
like understanding of how to entertain a
crowd there's one point he scores right
here and he's just enter just the whole
crowd is just like enamored by him it's
like amazing to watch he is practicing
he's practicing being entertaining eight
hours a day on stream yeah and he sees
what's entertaining what isn't because
the people that are tapping in and
leaving based on how entertaining he is
yeah so it's just on feedback exact time
eight hours a day exactly I just hope
that's just him naturally and not on any
substances uh do you think he might be
doing I don't think we were just talking
like yeah there's people that are like
that in the past let's say um Russell
Brand back in the day that he just was
just so entertaining like you couldn't
take your eyes off and I didn't realize
that whole time he was [ __ ] high yeah
yeah I mean he's so young that you think
he isn't but you never know yeah and
even Danny Brown he used to be crazy and
we didn't I didn't know that he was high
on drugs you know it's I was talking to
Beast about him and uh he was like
wildly entertaining and he goes he has
two modes I was like what is he like
when he's there he's like he's either
chilling by himself quiet or on fire so
he just knows how to turn it off yeah
yeah it's like camera's on that's go
time all right guys we're gonna take a
break from this exclusive patreon clip
because I got to make sure you don't
tear up your lungs and you're gonna do
that with the freeze pipe okay the best
Bongs in the [ __ ] business look
at this not only are they beautiful
impressive okay you ask a chick to come
over you pull out one of these she don't
know what to do she don't know what to
do you ask a dude to come over maybe
you're trying to hook up with a dude
ladies or fellas you know what I mean
you bust out one of these he might sit
on it that's how comfy these are and he
doesn't even know about the glycerin
chambers that make it extra cool why do
you think they call it the freeze pipe
that smoke is extra cool coming into
your throat and lungs okay fast forward
it's sliding down your throat into your
lungs fast forward with the freeze pipe
because the freeze pipe has got your
back them glycerin Chambers
I'm telling you never had smoke this
cold okay you're not going to be
coughing throat on fire you're gonna be
taking the biggest bong rips you've ever
taken your life thank God to the freeze
pipe they got it and they got your back
okay so for the smoothest glass pieces
at every day great prices go to
thefreeze pipe.com use the code flagrant
you're gonna get 15 off your order
that's thefreeze pipe.com use the code
flagrant for 15 off shop today your
throat and your lungs well thank you now
let's get back to this exclusive patreon
clip you could join the [ __ ] Army and
you should at patreon.com I mean this is
crazy so like offsides right
scores actually kind of impressive yeah
it was good goal
he's fired the whole crowd does the
Ronaldo thing it's like part of the
brand
finds out his offsides
like runs over takes his shirt off
tries to go fight the ref
ER to the National Treasure
Christian day is playing bodyguard right
now
someone's explaining the rules to him he
doesn't understand the rules of soccer
assistant referee pissed off goes and
gets his shirt gets the yellow card
don't give me that [ __ ]
I'll give you a yellow card watch this
runs over to the ref
let me spank some like he's just like an
absolute character he's just I don't
know he's impressive
unbelievable am I crazy for being am I
dick riding no no no it's unbelievable
why what's the pushback no you know
what's impressive first time it's funny
like it's fun yeah but like to get it
the first time he's the first one to
like I also didn't realize 30 million
people were watching this and he just
made so many [ __ ] fans like he stole
more fans than everybody yeah at that
entire and what's interesting is he
keeps on getting kicked off platforms
and then just keeps on getting bigger so
he's got to feel like he doesn't have to
change anything that he does no of
course it's gonna work out which
platform is he on now YouTube he was
kicked off YouTube but apparently I
think he's still streaming on YouTube
yeah I don't exactly he's off twitch
he's on Twitch yeah but it's wild
they're like they kick him off and he
finds a way back on and people go follow
him I mean he's throwing it keeps
stopping the Antics the question is is
it just gonna meet a self-destruct event
he keeps on pushing it like Logan Paul
said this he was like I was making Vlogs
every day I was pushing it farther and
farther and farther I pushed it too far
unfortunately it didn't involve like me
you know risking someone's life or
whatever the [ __ ] I just like
capitalized on this terrible [ __ ]
event this tragedy and that was the
thing that saved my life so my question
is which I sounds dramatic but like is
he in a position where he's like upping
the stream every single day
to where he's gonna push it too far also
point out he's 17.
holy [ __ ] so yes he'll push it too far
yeah just a few things that I've seen
I'm like the questions
no I said I didn't realize he was 17. I
thought he was a bit older I guess the
question I have is like eventually what
are you gonna do
like what are you gonna do what is the
job going to be are you going to
continue streaming and getting kicked
off and then demonetizing is that just
this constant battle or do you end up
doing something that is sustainable that
you won't be kicked off of and you can
make a living doing
I mean he's making a living
he is yeah he's probably making crazy
money but do we know this like what the
platform is where he's streaming who's
paying him like are you going to be too
dangerous that not even sponsors will
come [ __ ] with the things you don't need
sponsors when you're streaming that is
the beauty of streaming you're just
getting paid direct yeah so send me a
dollar I'll read your thing yeah
it's crazy he's probably making crazy
money yeah 17 years old
can't live with his parents probably
paid off their house I mean like you're
in a great position yeah it's what is
sustainable in terms of as to me it's
like as you get older I think you get a
little tired of giving this much energy
like if you're 35 doing that [ __ ] so and
I'm not saying he's gonna do it for 18
years but what does he transition to I
think is kind of what you're getting at
yeah and to me that's even almost more
so than what are the sponsors gonna [ __ ]
with this what am I going to want to do
when I'm 30. yeah I was trying to think
of like who like what he reminds me of
he reminds me of
your GTA character
so like he is complete impulsivity he is
there's no concern about what could
happen or what could go wrong just doing
the thing you want to do in the moment
right you saw the video that him having
to grow on his shoulders no he's in the
pool doing like a pool stream with like
some chick she like gets on his
shoulders and he's just sitting there
he's like she's like I can get off and
he goes no no no I can feel your [ __ ]
on my neck like he just says like he
just says the crazy thing that you're
not supposed to say but you kind of
think every moment yeah never wondering
what the [ __ ] it is doing the craziest
thing I'm gonna go tackle KSI most
people go oh [ __ ] what if I injure him
and then he could be out of his next
fight he could lose millions of dollars
it's just go the second the lights and
the cameras are on what is the most
entertaining thing to do and that's
video games right because there are no
Stakes GTA in particular yeah and I
think we're almost watching
what a human would do if there's no
repercussions and the issue is there are
repercussions yeah yes and it's gonna be
interesting interesting to see if he
pulls it back God damn is it
entertaining bro it is crazy but this is
what we said for the first time we
talked about I'm like yo you need a
mentor you need like a dude do you need
someone I wonder if there's some people
because how does he get to England
what do you mean like they're inviting
him there right like yeah so it's like
he's either they're either he's 17 so
they're either talking to the parents
they're like there's somebody else
involved I don't think as a 17 year old
you're like okay let me go get my
passport like did you guys have
passports at 17 well you were traveling
yeah I did you guys all had passed but I
think maybe I did I'm just trying to say
there's like yeah
there's reasons like you need some other
people around you that are going to help
with these types of things so he's got
to have like a management just because
there's people around doesn't mean
they're looking outfit and doesn't mean
they can tell you [ __ ] like his dad is
in his life I think like uh involved I
think there's an interview Grand wizard
posted of him and his dad and Speedy's
doing the dick sucking thing his dad's
like slapping his ass but what's your
dad really gonna tell you when you're
making millions of dollars yeah exactly
you better start doing this yeah do it
yeah so I that's the thing when you're
that successful that young no
repercussions yet whatever repercussions
he meets it don't matter they're not
real repercussions yeah so what are you
gonna tell this kid that's the the scary
part is being that young and no
repercussions you don't nobody can tell
you [ __ ] and there's no real
consequences yet eventually there are
but I I still know when he meets him
yeah yeah that's a boomerass
conversation to have bro what what are
the consequences yeah speed those are
crazy [ __ ] being like but yeah but yeah
it is a boomerang download have but it's
also like we're coming from people who
have been in entertainment for a while
yeah and it's like we are on we've seen
the people pop and we've seen people
flame out and you recognize Talent the
kids got [ __ ] Talent he knows how to
Garner eyeballs and then you're like how
long can you do this you know six nine
is not like this but like this in some
ways and then he's like I'm gonna do the
Wild Thing and what his wild thing was
I'm gonna beef with all these people who
were really dangerous and now he's in a
position where he can't even tour
remember uh boonk I think his name yeah
you know you went crazy and then now he
can't do any other [ __ ] but he turned
around though now he's like a Christian
rapper yeah who's really checking for
him what do you mean like yeah it's
lucrative he fell off John Gabbana is
his name yeah but he's alive though like
yeah when you're at where he was at in
his life like and he talks about it like
yo I'm addicted to drugs I don't have
anything I lose all my girlfriends I
think he's got a kid that he like lost
custody of or some [ __ ] yeah and all of
a sudden he's like oh I'm alive and
stable like that's the best [ __ ] that's
more important than being on I think one
more thing is like we don't want that to
happen to speak I don't want him to lose
that and also like how do you just
sustain this level of entertainment yeah
like yeah ideally keep entertaining in a
way that's fun yeah yeah and uh
yeah I think yeah and I think most
people don't think it might be a boomer
combo but like most people aren't
thinking about like them and they're
just going yeah keep on doing the wild
[ __ ] yeah until it's too wild and that
he can't do it no more and then they're
like man I'll just find someone else as
well or emulating yeah yeah